>>> MATT GAETZ'S FORMER ALLY
PLEADS GUILTY TO SIX FEDERAL
CHARGES AND PAYING UNDER AGE
GIRLS FOR SEX.
>> DOES MY CLIENT INFORMATION
THAT HURT AN ELECTED OFFICIAL?
I GUESS IT IS JUST, YOU KNOW,
MUST-SEE TELEVISION, YOU HAVE TO
WAIT AND SEE.
PAULA REED IS OUT FRONT.
YOU WERE IN THE COURTROOM TODAY
AND WHAT DID YOU SEE AND WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN FOR GAETZ?
>> Reporter: ERIN, WHAT WAS SO
REMARKABLE IN THE COURTHOUSE IS
SEEING THIS GREENBERG WHO
BRAGGED ABOUT SPENDING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS ON
PROSTITUTES AND SEX PARTIES AND
HE WAS THERE AND HE WAS IN A
PRISON JUMP SUIT.
HE HAD HANDCUFFS AND BIG CHAIN
AROUND HIS WAIST.
THAT'S HOW IT IS GOING TO BE FOR
HIM FOR A DECADE.
HE WAS QUIET AS HE WHISPERED YES
OR NO TO THE JUDGE.
FRAUD, CONSPIRACY AND STALKING.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
ADMISSIONS HE MADE IS HE NOT
ONLY HAD SEX WITH A MINOR BUT HE
INTRODUCED THIS CHILD TO OTHER
ADULT MEN WHO PAID HER FOR SEX.
THAT'S THE BIG QUESTION, WHO
WERE THESE OTHER MEN AND HAVE HE
IMPLICATED CONGRESSMAN MATT
GAETZ.
GREENBERG'S LAWYER HAD NOT
REVEAL WHAT HIS CLIENT SAID.
IN ADDITION TO DENYING ANY
ALLEGATIONS, THEY ARE ATTACKING
JOEL GREENBERG CREDIBILITY.
JOEL GREENBERG IS AN ADMITTED
FELON.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE ADMITTED
THAT FALSELY ACCUSING A TEACHER
WHO CHALLENGED HIM OF HIS TAX
AND ACCUSING THAT TEACHER BEING
A PEDOPHILE.
THE INVESTIGATORS ARE NOT SOLELY
RELYING ON THE WORDS OF
GREENBERG.
THEY HAD HUNDREDS OF DOCUMENTS
AND OTHER WITNESSES.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT ALL THESE
THINGS TO ASSESS WHETHER THEY
HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO CHARGE
THE CONGRESSMAN.
>> SUCH A CRUCIAL POINT, PAULA
REID.
THANK YOU, ANYTHING HE SAYS
THEY'LL HAVE COMPLETELY BACKED
UP DOCUMENTATIONS FOR THE REASON
SHE JUST LAID OUT.
LAURA COACH JOINS ME NOW.
JOEL GREENBERG'S LAWYER, DOES HE
HAVE INFORMATION THAT CAN HURT
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL?
I GUESS THIS IS SUCH INFORMATION
AND YOU HAVE TO WAIT AND SEE.
>> REMEMBER YOU DON'T GO FROM 30
SOMETHING CHARGES DOWN TO SIX
UNLESS YOU HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BE
AN ASSISTANT TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THERE MAY BE A NOTE FOR THIS
ATTORNEY TO MAKE SURE THE
PROSECUTOR WHO ULTIMATELY WILL
HAVE A DECISION TO SAY WHAT SORT
OF SENTENCE THIS PERSON WILL
HAVE AND HE'S REALLY VALUABLE,
KEEP HIM AS A COOPERATOR,
REMINDING THE PROSECUTORS AS
MUCH AS THE PEOP